reg Hillary good morning Theodor I am so
excited to walk the red carpet not only
with you but my Danette family as well I
know we normally sit in the back and
watch the bossman do his thing but to be
a united front team like I'm looking
forward to it
okay could you wear oh you didn't go to
the NBA Draft when when you were
selected right I did not I was home in
Riverside with my family watching it on
believe it was on TV yes at the time
okay cuz I was wondering I saw where
Jalen Rose brought back his NBA draft
suit and I didn't know you could still
fit in your NBA draft suit if you had
one I'm guessing I'm assuming it was
probably a sports coat and not a suit I
didn't have a suit back in the day I had
a lot of sport codes I probably could
body wise I grew a little bit since my
senior year like an inch and a half but
I could make it work I could rock it but
I got you with jean shorts on like are
these white jeans when you're drafted I
know it was a bad luck I didn't know I
believe I had like a don't foul out hat
on or something like that it wasn't a
great look more importantly how about
this look at the couch that was in our
living room in Riverside Laurel solitary
the full couch holy Moses but it sure
was comfortable there was nice change in
there pops have come home from the base
and you would fall asleep after work and
you know quarters and dives would fall
out we were on our way to 7-eleven so it
was a comfortable couch I can see all of
Cheryl's trophies in the background do
you see the smallest trophy that's like
behind us that was all those Naismith
and big trophies and awards and those
were all Cheryl Dean alright we'll talk
about the draft but here's a couple
things the Lakers were told that San
Antonio is not interested in trading
Kawhi Leonard that's the report what do
you make of
well duh why would San Antonio help
arrival out and why would they help form
a potential super team a team that
they're gonna have to go against four
times during the regular season and
potentially in the playoffs if they are
which I still believe they are not going
to deal Kawhi Leonard they're gonna deal
them to the east where they would only
have to see them twice you know they are
not going to trade quite Leonard if they
end up doing that to a Western
Conference team they are not going to
help out any team out west
all right there was a another I saw this
headline and it said where Kobe Altman
who's the GM the Cavs said he had a good
dialogue with LeBrons people what would
that what would good dialogue constitute
to you mr. James here's a blank check I
know I think the max can be 36 to 37
million how would you want us and which
free agents do you want us to pursue who
would you be willing to call to see if
they are willing to come and play with
you a great dialogue is basically doing
whatever LeBron James wants and needs
for him to stay in Cleveland so if
that's getting Paul George if that's
bringing in Chris Paul it's those type
of conversations if you're mr. Altman
you have to have with LeBron James I at
the end of the day still believe he's
going to leave I mean he's done
everything that he said he's wanted to
do in Cleveland and that's we're in the
championship and I just don't see free
agents wanting to come to Cleveland yeah
and play with him and to me that's the
biggest thing and ask that's why I just
think he has his bags packed that's just
my personal opinion well Charles Barkley
and Shaq both said LeBron should not be
chasing rings for his legacy now these
are two guys who chased rings so what do
you think of LeBron chasing rings
well I just think wherever he ends up
you become a super team because he's
going to be able to attract other than
Cleveland free agent so if he does go to
Philadelphia the infrastructure is
already there with the young talent with
embiid and Simmons and Sarich but
Houston you guys you know obviously
Chris Paul if he opts in and James
Harden you become a superpower with
LeBron James I'm he look his legacy is
set he is what is the greatest to ever
play the game
and but to be recognized as the greatest
you got to chase rings here reg and I
think LeBron
I don't think LeBron is going you know
I'm satisfied if I never play for
another title again or I don't win
another title line that sound like
LeBron James 90 LeBron James always has
to be in the mix yes so I I don't think
it's necessarily him chasing rings I
think he wants to assemble the best
possible team our surroundings over the
best possible talent and team to compete
versus Golden State but if he stays in
Cleveland you're not chasing a ring if
you leave then people are going to
define that as chasing a ring well to me
it's about quality of life too and I
believe his kids are getting ready to
enter high school and he's probably
starting a new chapter in terms of that
and their development and form I
understand they maybe go into school out
here in Los Angeles so now that factors
back in and the Lakers are our back in
play but I don't see him playing for the
Lakers so to me it's all about quality
of life I think his legacy to me is
already set weight you don't see him
playing for the Lakers you see him if he
goes out playing for the Clippers
possibly I can see him more so playing
for the Clippers than I would the Lakers
why I don't think he wants to follow in
Kobe Bryant shadow I think if he goes to
the Clippers right now he could be
arguably the greatest cook forever in
three to four years
be the greatest okay who is the best
clipper of all time you would throw
Blake you would throw Chris Paul well
that's Chris Paul
Danny Manny but look how hard we're
having to think about this right if Ron
James went to the Clippers he would be
the greatest Clipper of all time in one
season so you think one season you
distinct that he doesn't want to follow
in Kobe's footsteps in that that'd be
the biggest reason why a big shadow
that's a big shadow because if he
doesn't win everyone's gonna be like
well he's not Kobe and now it goes the
pecking order and memory you and I are
not supposed to be doing this but
regular fans are gonna be like Michael
Vick Kobe and then probably LeBron
because he couldn't deliver a
championship to the Lakers there were a
lot of big guys drafted last night and
and my point is it's one thing to be
seven feet but it's how you play at
seven feet and you know Durant seven
feet but he doesn't play like a seven
footer so is the NBA shifting back at
all to having a post presence here or is
this just an aberration of you had the
best guys are at that size and you know
that doesn't mean that the league is is
skewing that way I will always take
sighs but you look at most of the bigs
that were drafted last night other than
even Bamba mo bomber can face you up and
knock down the three
jaren Jackson even though it's a set
shot can face up and knock down threes
when uncontested on DeAndre the number
one pick he talks about wanting to be
one of those players to play with his
back to the basket but he can face you
up as well it's it's been the sign of
the times for our league your big men
have to be able to do multiple things
you just can't play like Shaquille with
your back to the basket and be dominant
you've got to be able to face the
defense and keep them honest by knocking
down you know a 15 to 18 footers if
you're good enough to stretch it out to
the three-point line that's great
and also defensive
you've got to be able to switch all
pick-and-rolls
that's the way our game has gone and
you've got to be able to to move your
feet at least three to four steps either
way to keep the guard in front until the
guard can to your defensive guard can
catch up so that's what your big men
have to be able to do in today's game as
opposed to just throwing it down low on
the block and saying you know go get me
25 points
who do you think of Murray if I gave you
the top five players in the draft and
then I took the rest of the field on who
is gonna have the most all-star
appearances would you take the top five
players in the draft or would you give
me everybody else in this draft yeah I
would give you everyone else I it's hard
to say what these guys are gonna do it's
great seven footers athleticism Jay
Bilas kept harping on and he's right
about the wingspan you know six five but
he got a seven-foot I mean I get all
that
I get the analytics but see it or do you
really know I mean are you really sold
on DeAndre Aiden really turn around the
fortunes of the Phoenix Suns I'm not no
I mean Bagley who was I thought was
great in his one year at Duke but is he
really going to change Sacramento Kings
are they really like in contention now
to make a playoff spot I mean they'll be
better I think but you don't know I do
like what Elena did I think getting the
shooter Kevin shooter and obviously Trey
young and that trade was Danka CH and
then picking up Spelman I thought
Spelman was a fantastic player for
Villanova on that championship team
I like those three pieces for Atlanta
they'll be better but again at the end
of a there's still three rookies but
they'll be better in time they can grow
together yeah I would take the rest of
the field I'm just not sure I don't know
if there's one of those transcendent
franchise players in the draft I said
yesterday that I wouldn't be surprised
if Dallas went after don't check just
because if you if you can get him and
put him in there with Dennis Smith jr.
with one more year with Dirk well maybe
that's a nice transitional guy you can
have
Derk and helping with the transition you
know you have now you're interesting to
watch and as you know you know Orlando
has been irrelevant because there's just
no reason to watch them Atlanta there's
no reason to watch them I'm gonna watch
what tre Young Sacramento there is a
there's a mild curiosity I have a
Sacramento like I they may accidentally
get it right you know but I I'm you just
don't want to be irrelevant and some of
these franchises are irrelevant and even
these draft picks like jaren Jackson jr.
he could be a great player but he's
playing in Memphis and I'm you're really
gonna watch him if it's not yeah that's
great now don't get me wrong and he's
gonna be teamed with Marc Gasol and
obviously Mike Conley jr. Mike Conley
coming back from injury so that helps
but okay are you tuning in oh my god the
Memphis Grizzlies are on because jaren
Jackson jr. is married no no but I want
to see and you talked about dumb kids
Luca dumb kids I mean what a perfect fit
for one more year to learn under Dirk
Nowitzki I would park my locker right
next to his and every day I would come
in with an index card with a question on
it saying mr. Nowitzki can you please
answer this question and yes I would
address them as mister can you please
answer this question for me and I would
have a question every single day for
Dirk if I was Luca can you teach that
move the Dirk move thank you Kevin
direct Kevin Durant picked it up so
obviously you can teach it but why don't
more guys do that because it it's it
already gives me separation where I can
I can kick my leg out and I got
separation from you and the fact that
I'm seven feet tall so it's really hard
to block Durant and Dirk Sean well
number one you've got to be an elite
scorer like those two guys have been
throughout their whole careers and
you've got to have size I mean both are
seven footers you know and both have
high release points on their jump shots
now you're telling me that they have
that separation because of that what is
it a me or I think it's a need it's a
knee
there's no way you're blocking that shot
and you're fading away a little bit as
well but yeah it's very difficult to
master those are two of the best
obviously dirt created it but Kevin
Durant has put a new spin on it I got
into this phone discussion text
discussion with Darius Rucker and he
said you're starting your team Vince
Carter or Dirk Nowitzki wow wow that's
very good
I'm a I'm a go a dirt yeah I would too
I'm a go a dirt if I have a chance to
win I want Dirk if I have a chance to
just be average and I want to entertain
then I got Vince Carter they'll take it
yeah yeah I mean I'm not discrediting
Vince convinced obviously a Hall of Fame
career yeah but at least Dirk is a
double-double - you know points and
rebounds we under right we had a guy who
drove up from Tampa with his family just
to ask a question in the parking lot
and he'd ask mclovin ask Dan if Carmelo
Anthony's a Hall of Famer and I went he
drove all the way from Tampa for for
that for an obvious answer like Mel was
a Hall of Famer yeah he's a Hall of
Famer yeah remember people it's body of
work and remember he won an NCAA
Championship at Syracuse okay who would
go in first
Carmelo or Vince
Carmelo just because of the title in
college or was he a better player well I
see Paul II look this up in terms of
points who's ahead right now I believe
Carmelo that what 24 25 right thousand
points oh right now I would have to say
Carmelo Vince is probably low 20s didn't
he
these low 20s right so points wise I
think Kamel was ahead of them those are
going in both will be first valid
I believe Carmelo that at least
twenty-four twenty-five thousand yeah
Paulie I've got this is closer than
you'd expect Carmelo Anthony is at
twenty five thousand four hundred and
seventeen points Vince Carter
still counting is that twenty four
thousand eight hundred and sixty eight
wow wow wow well because of the Syracuse
chip right yeah yeah you that's got to
mean something and wanted as a freshman
you know how many guys would take Vince
Carter's jumping skills at 41 like if
you say coming into the league and you
jump you're gonna jump like this Carter
at 41 yeah well there's a guy who kept
his body in immaculate shape so it's not
surprising yeah that's pretty good
all right so next week's a big week for
us Reggie we got ready now wait red
carpet afterparty obviously I mean we're
going
oh yeah we're toasting baby really
afterparty
with my dad s and you obviously did or
is there bottle service wrench wait
when's the last time you went to a club
and had been in the club will get who
was first team all Club when you played
first team Oh al Rodman she's probably
CEO right yeah okay I would go with
Rodman um first team all club do you
ever smell alcohol and Rodman no okay
but you just look in his eyes like he
had one of them kind of nice and it was
almost like not only did he have one of
those kind of nice he kind of wish you
were with him because you know he was at
some probably some nice strip clubs we
probably had all the girls around them
dude partied hard but he played harder
on the court Reggie we got it done
you could have hung with Rodman no I
know I could you wouldn't want to hang
with Rodman no I saw it I saw it up
close one night in Chicago and I went
man that no can't no no no no no okay he
had a he had the entire bar a private
bar that was full of kamikazes and every
time you went to get a beer he made you
do a kamikaze every single time cuz he
was controlling the bar tab he's like
bro he kept Kate always called me Sager
he'd go hey I do a kamikaze I'm just
getting a Budweiser there and he had his
arm around a guy and a girl with a
Chicago police shirt on and who knows
what happened after that I I just know
that Dennis did not get treated that
night Rodman's best game ever came
against you guys March of 92 Rodman had
34 rebounds while a member of the Bulls
or a member of the Pistons was March of
92 I'm gonna guess
was he with he was with the Spurs in he
yeah he had 34 rebounds when he was with
Spurs oh my god come on
[Laughter]
but he didn't guard you did he no well
yes
on switches oh okay but he didn't he
would never viewer the Bell
he would never no he's not that dumb you
might switch on a switch or coming off a
screen you might show up but he's not
know
no he's not that dumb he knows better he
had sings better he how many did Reggie
have in a game oh boy yeah and did we
win or lose
if you got thirty four rebounds a better
of lon Robin had thirty four rebounds
and ten points Reggie oh no oh no did
Reggie get double figures reg was 3 for
6 from the field
Oh for one from three and only six
points in 36 minutes Rodman shut you
down oh no did maybe he did Garvey's
okay well how many minutes did I play
you played you played 36 minutes yeah
then he called me you know who outscored
you Gregg Dreiling maybe 92 so who is my
coach in 92 I'm gonna go with who was
our coach in 1990 you're gonna blame
your coach yeah that's what the
modern-day players do now they always
blame their like I like it six points
reg six points are you sure about that
poly I'm 1992 I hate to say it Michael
William some guy named Michael Williams
had 28 for you guys he carried a gap
Francine carried it Bob Hill what was
the game played in the Alamodome or in
Market Square it was that actually at
the Pistons it was a Pistons game and
Pacers pistol was up it you know I know
what happened I was getting hits no
shame
okay because if it was the Smurfs I'm
really disappointed that I only had six
points versus the Spurs in 92 but now
that you said bad boys okay yeah I'll
get my bell rung that's what happens
shut you down all right we'll see you
next week we got the premiere of uncle
Drew and then reg will join us in studio
as well so I'll talk to you next week
that's a Reggie Aloysius Miller form or
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]